hello and welcome to this video playing
the integrator again let's see you is
going to deviate probably me I was
sticking I'm sticking with my my line
here Queen d3 this time this is a bit
different quite clearly home so what
what about this
now Queen 85 is not working interesting
interesting line I don't want to go back
yeah I mean queen have six wins material
but I absolutely don't don't want to
grab that it looks super dangerous and
maybe I have to I mean maybe I have to
check this is definitely super dangerous
white hands full compensation for the
exchange maybe more yeah we have nothing
developed I interesting stuff Quincy to
is a move that is completely it's never
played essentially if you look in the
database um you simplified like one or
two games and when I analyze it I felt
it was very interesting very interesting
option for white okay so if i go here
how to untangle this stuff we have six
don't get a wrong impression i don't
like this position it's just that I
somehow yeah I have not checked how I
should play it and wow there be five I
mean I don't want to play he six it
looks completely ridiculous but maybe I
have to be five I'm if he goes be fine I
cannot move anything well yeah I also
cannot move anything how to do that look
the 85
hook g8 is rook d for I guess what about
no thinking be five
Wow I definitely have to check this line
I don't want to get this again against
him I'm not much with Han for prepping
for blitz games but this is an
absolutely ridiculous position for black
yeah do I want to take this and then he
goes Luke c7 next how would we ever move
p 5
maybe it's ghosts Quincy cell
maybe be five in this position be five
you cannot take it on pass all it could
be maybe this is an idea I can probably
just take a shot huh and this I didn't
expect ah ok this is the thing here text
this phone now hmm ok ok
like till I have six I got and what a
bloody disaster you can just take edge
h7 here threaten you gauge a it takes it
he says there's going to be more than
strong compensation here yep definitely
you Bishop e7 I can take these seven I'm
just a bunch of a bunch of nonsense you
and age six black resigns yep I have to
recheck this line this this is a
position that's probably objectively bad
and it has come on God you should know
that I don't take this this bloody reach
challenges there after declining a
couple of times so I mean yeah so let's
have a look again here queen bee three
yourself ah ok ok ok ok now now we're
getting somewhere and the engine gives a
solution right away tonight e2m this is
this is what I have to play but this is
a lot stronger is a lot stronger the
difference is in the position with queen
or ditch with as Bishop e2 now which is
impossible now if he if he sacrifices
this is a stronger this is a bit better
now because I've also snatched the e
porn it is still it is still not not
looking great i have
to admitted hi do a kit kat this has
something else that I can play hmm yeah
this this this is bad just bad and this
now is also chat they have to play that
yeah this this gives white phenomenal
compensation and this is yeah and tae
has to the engine this is an interesting
case yeah the engine wants to go to be
one and I think this isn't a big deal I
mean here let's say create five the
trade stuff happened and this is okay I
mean this is ok I can defend this
position or maybe d 6 or something yeah
King you seven Ruby idea this is okay
I'm not saying I'm better but nothing
nothing bad happens here so the engine
doesn't doesn't understand that it has
to give more material here this is the
critical line clearly takes takes
castles Bishop f4
yeah this is just just looking awful I
mean you have an exchange and the porn
but how do you ever develop
now that's an unplayable although not in
blitz I mean maybe even it's just bad
anyway it looks bad yeah I have to check
this I have to check this yeah very very
tricky yet the way the way it went we
can briefly look at that but it is not
much fun to look at White's compensation
is just fantastic even over the Queen
trade here yeah I kill you I really
couldn't see how to how to potentially
untangle you this place this position I
simply cannot move yeah and this is
losing it just loses yeah I wanted to I
mean you know lash out try to get out of
this stuff but it didn't work of course
it's a it's a pretty awful awful
situation here you're so passive anyway
thanks for watching